well good morning everyone I'm Robert
Jackson Marcel thank you for that very
kind introduction I teach corporate law
and corporate finance here at the law
school and I'm very excited to have the
opportunity to share the launch of the
crown website with you today we
announced crown about 18 months ago and
the nature of our objective but I want
to back up and give you a sense for
really what inspired him but but it was
was our sense that the debates over
corporate law and corporate governance
are at the moment anyway a little less
influenced by data and a little more
influenced by belief than they should be
you know the debates over corporate
governance in the last year or two
especially if taking on the sense of
kind of like a holy war for geeks they
sort of there's sort of people on one
side who think that it's shareholder
power we should be concerned about
there's another side that comes to the
defense of the corporate board and our
view and IRAs plea to me was what does
the evidence tell us who are the
shareholders who are the people who are
making the voting decisions in big
public companies and the answer is we
don't really know and the reason we
don't really know is that until now
there hasn't been undertaken a
significant large-scale data driven
project that tries to take the evidence
we have out there on who shareholders
are and what they care about and bring
it to bear on these debates to be sure
there's been a lot of empirical study in
this area not hard to find to find good
empirical work in a field my colleague
at the business school for Breezy o
fairies here today he's authored a
number of studies just like that but a
lot of the data and the work that he
does and the work that I've done until
now has been based on hand drawn
datasets that is fundamentally data
where we send our researchers or
assistance and us to websites we grab
the information we keep track of it and
we produce a study that can tell you it
takes a long time it's error-prone and
it gives us a bias in our work in that
we tend to look only at the biggest
companies the ones where we can get data
and not all of the companies that we're
interested in talking about so a year
and a half ago iris said to me I want to
bring data to bear on this and he had
frankly the ambition and the vision
ask me and to sit down with me and say
how do we do that and it turns out we
got lucky because just at the moment
that IRA asked me that question there
had been a series of breakthroughs in
data science actually to our friends in
the data Science Institute here at
Columbia this is old news but for us it
was very exciting the idea is that you
can take documents and text that use
consistently identifiable patterns and
you can use statistics to understand
where the data you care about resides
and take it out and what we've done over
the last 18 months is develop a lab
inside the law school as far as I know
the only one at a major law school that
is a data science laboratory and this is
our homepage that spends all of its time
thinking about how do we take SEC
filings and key market information and
make it available to researchers in the
public now i want to tell you when i
started this my interest in this game
was just to get the data because i write
papers for a living in the more data i
have the more papers i can write and i
like the idea of having a whole team of
people who get me data but an important
development happened about a year ago
and that was Bill McCracken taking on
leadership of the center because he
added an additional challenge he said
listen Rob you know you're going to come
up with tons of data and that's cool but
what you really want to do is give
information to the world your challenge
is to take that kind of data and make it
accessible give people a place where if
they want to figure out what the CEO of
a public company makes they can type in
a ticker and get it lickety-split or if
they want to know who are the owners of
the company a quarter ago they can put
in a ticker and get it for free and as a
result of that what we did was take a
further step with our work in addition
to data extraction we've begun to do
what we refer to as data visualization
what we're going to show you today is a
series of pictures that the crown
website generates automatically for all
of you to see the relationships we care
about in corporate governance now as
Marcel explain this is a an alpha
version of our product there are
machines at the back computers at the
back and we want you to go back and play
around with it I'm just going to give
you a small taste of what this does it's
not a perfect product it's we're still
working on it by its nature statistical
machine learning the technology we're
using to get at the data is one that
improves over time
because it evaluates documents and the
text that's in them builds a regression
that figures out what I'm looking for
and grabs it and the more I can teach it
the better it will be at extracting what
we need but we're excited enough and we
feel like we're ready to show you a
little bit about crown today now i
should say this website for the data lab
features not only crown which is really
the centerpiece of our work but other
work we've done lately to marcel
mentioned a couple of these projects and
i'll talk a little bit about them before
i wrap up today but let's start um
really what and just to give you a sense
these visualizations include things that
we think you're going to like and use
like for example we have a new tool that
allows you to grab any merger agreement
from the SEC s website figure out what
law firm represented each side and
understand what the reps and warranties
look like we'll talk a little bit more
about that later but for now let's start
with crown the centerpiece of our work
you can click on the labs website
they'll take you to crown and launch
this visualization and this picture that
you're seeing here is really just
automatically produced by statistical
machine learning that extracts
information on shareholdings of the
largest public companies and displays
these relationships to you graphically
what you're seeing here is for the
largest 50 public companies in the
United States who are their shareholders
and what the graph does is just show you
the relationships between those
shareholders and the companies that they
own so for example if you want to know
who are the shareholders at the center
of the corporate governance world for
these folks it's the usual suspects it's
Vanguard at state street its Bank of New
York it's all of the custodians that
hold major shares in large public
companies but what we like a lot about
this is not only does it give you a
sense for how the largest 50 public
companies are owned and you can see that
they have a lot of owners in common in
the network map it also allows you to
play with the website graphically by
going through so for example suppose we
wanted to get a sense for a public
company that we're interested in
learning more about suppose we wanted to
get a sense for Apple the graph will
tell us these are the owners of Apple
and if we click on Apple's logo it'll
take us to the homepage of Apple and I I
can't stress this enough what's
interesting about this product is this
is all automatically produced this is a
machine run
in the background taking the SCC's most
recent filings using statistics to
figure out what information we want and
make it available to the public now in
the case of Apple you can see some
familiar friends first of all it grabs
information on on Apple's details what
it does where where its headquarters is
the famous logo that we all know so well
and then it lists every director or
officer of that company that's ever
served at Apple you can see some old
friends and famous names like Al Gore
who served on that board for some time
and what the website does is extract
from SEC filings details on data we're
all interested in so to give you an
example you could figure out a little
bit if you'd like about executive
compensation at apple and what's
happening now is the machine is looking
on the SEC filings grabbing the proxy
statements that have ever been filed for
Apple using statistics to find the data
and present it to you and you can see
the history of executive compensation at
Apple it gives you every individual that
we have data on and then you can see a
little spike in that graph everybody
knows who that is right that's Tim
Cook's famous 375 million dollar stock
award from a couple of years ago and if
you scroll down we like that we provide
this graphically to you because bill
challenged us to show you data give you
information not just data but we have it
in tabular format to and researchers
will be able to extract these data and
use them in research you might by the
way have the reaction you know executive
compensation data is already out there
that's true but it applies only to the
S&P 1500 or so everything I'm showing
you now we have for every public company
and every public investor in the United
States because our methods because they
don't rely on hand drawing because they
don't rely on labor can be applied to
any company that's made a filing with
the SEC I said the point of the project
was to figure out more about owners that
was irish challenge to us a couple of
years ago and what we're what we're
doing here is not only extracting the
information on the companies and things
like executive comp which has been those
data have been available for some time
but we're also linking them to ownership
data which we extract from other 13f
filings
of of major investors so if you want to
know who's investing in apple and who um
who likes apples stock no surprise
that's our old friends Blackrock who
owned a very significant stake and we're
listening for you here every investor
that's reported a significant position
in Apple in their 13f filings for the
last quarter and again one thing I like
about this is that you can actually
click on the data and it'll take you to
get further information so let's take
Blackrock for example and learn a little
bit more about them so Blackrock very
well-known institutional investor you
might want to learn a little bit more
about who they are and what they're
invested in and here we ran against a
very interesting challenge because those
of you who know this area well and the
data you know that Black Rock doesn't
file one filing with the sec it's not
like Blackrock shows up to the SEC it
says hi We're Blackrock we manage four
trillion and here's all the information
you want if only it were so know what
Blackrock does is have two or three
dozen entities that file things with the
SEC so a major challenge in the product
in the project was building an algorithm
which we did and we filed actually a
patent application with the University
for this particular technology that uses
a series of factors their name the
address the details on who the entity is
to link up all of the things that are
associated with black rock in one place
and what you see here is another
relational map that gives you a sense
for all of the Blackrock entities we've
identified that have filings with the
Securities and Exchange Commission so
you can look at all their data at once
you might say I might want to look at
them separately you can do that too of
course but what you might prefer to do
is just understand Blackrock as a whole
and this allows you to do that now we
have two different sources of
information on a shareholder like
Blackrock one is data that you probably
know already the 13f that they file
quarterly that everybody has to disclose
what they own except for Warren Buffett
but but so they have the 13 f on a
quarterly basis but here we've got new
data that no one ever has ever has
disclosed and that's on a form known as
Form ADV anybody ever heard of this yeah
so I hadn't until I started this
this is an amazing form basically any
investment advisor has to write to the
SEC disclose all kinds of stuff assets
under management they have to disclose
how they're governed they have to
disclose who their managers are what
they own in the underlying entity how
they're paid all kinds of great detail
you might wonder how come researchers
really never used form ADV and there's a
simple answer the SEC allows you to get
each advisors like most recent ADV but
then when they file an update they take
down the old one and replace it with a
new one so researchers who want to see
things change over time we rely a lot on
changes over time to draw inferences
from data you can't so about a year ago
we made a FOIA request from the SEC and
ask them for all the information they
refused we appealed and won so we have
15 years of form ADV data for every
investment advisor who's ever filed that
information and it includes a lot of fun
stuff that I want to share with you
today so we've got all those details for
Blackrock let's start though with
something simple which is assets under
management here we're going to show you
you can just click on the on the web
page and see the amount of assets under
management that Black Rock has and we we
can account for a little over the four
trillion that Black Rock now holds and
you can get a sense both for the growth
of that number over time you are all
familiar of course with black rocks
explosive growth you also can get a
sense for how much of it is managed on a
discretionary basis how much is managed
a non-discretionary basis and then I
like this a lot if you scroll down you
can see what individual companies they
like you can get a sense for who Black
Rock is long and now Black Rock being a
bellwether sorry if you go back up you
can get a sense for their portfolio
allocation if you click click there on
the left and what you'll get or details
about not only how Black Rock has
invested across industries generally but
if you scroll down you'll get
information on the particular company so
who does Black Rock like well they're an
indexer so they like everybody else
likes apple they're like oil they like
ExxonMobil they're like Microsoft these
are obvious ones of course but you might
be interested in knowing a little more
for example you might want to know in a
particular industry
who does Blackrock like so if you grab
the one of the search tools that we
built for you and take for example just
mining you can get a sense here are the
companies that black rocks long in the
mining industry here's what they think
of one as opposed to the other and this
is really rich data that that that we've
assembled now one thing you might wonder
is this kind of data is it um is it
already out there there are some good
sources for 13f data but again we're
using here a technique that we feel it
gets at a broader range of of this kind
of data and gives you a little more
detail than you might have gotten
otherwise you scroll back up one thing
that I really like about about this
information is that it allows you to see
not only the holdings of the entity but
important governance details and i'll
give you my favorite example we have
evidence on the what are called the
disclosure reporting pages on Form ADV
which gives you information on every
civil criminal and regulatory infraction
these investment advisors have ever had
the disclosure is a little spotty to be
honest with you but it's also very
interesting so for example we're giving
you here in a time series every event on
the disclosure reporting page for
Blackrock that they've ever had every
criminal infraction every civil
infraction every regulatory event and if
you point the mouse over any in
particular you can see what the charge
was and what the resolution was so for
example in 2003 Blackrock had a little
issue with the SEC they settled it for
80 million bucks that's a tip for them
but they basically basically can see
every single infraction and right now
another senior fellow at the milstein
Center Martin kremers whose work you
might know and I are working on a paper
that takes these infractions and looks
to see what's the relationship between
this kind of behavior and things like
stock ownership is it associated with
more risk-taking less risk taking longer
term investment profiles or shorter and
that's a paper that we plan on releasing
next year you know if you look at
Blackrock they have a pretty clean
history especially given their size I
mean for me if you managed four trillion
that's not that's not so bad but if you
want there's
another way to go through crown and
explore what we've done you can just use
a search page where you're borrowing
from Google's technology here and you
can type in the name of any investment
advisor and see what kind of history
they've had with the authorities black
rocks had a pretty good run but let's
take another example I don't know
Goldman Sachs and you can find out what
Goldman Sachs relationship with its
regulators has been like over the last
few years they've had a little bit more
trouble so you can actually I'm one
thing I like about these data is that
it's extremely granular you know for a
guy like me what I want is variation in
the data because that helps me figure
things out and you can see there's a lot
of different variation in fact you can
zoom in on particular time periods and
figure out hey what happened at Goldman
in terms of these infractions during the
financial crisis you can figure out in
2008-2009 what kind of what kind of
information of what kind of infractions
they had this search function by the way
applies to any company investor or
individual who's ever had anything filed
under their name at the SEC so one thing
you can do if you want to have a little
fun today is go in the back and throw
your your boss's name in the in the
search engine see what you get like you
know if I wanted to misbehave we could
put McCracken's name in there there he
is there's how much you made we won't
spend too much time on that there's
another way you can you can take a look
at crown if you click on the main menu
bar we also made it navigable not only
by by by search functions and by the
graphs we produced but also you know we
wanted people to be able to just click
on the three main kinds of information
we had and play with the site so you can
click on the public companies page and
you can just get information on who are
the highest paid individuals at every
public company if you click on any of
these it will take you to the SEC filing
that produced that information if you
scroll down a little bit you can get a
sense for the companies that are owned
mostly by outsiders versus those owned
mostly by insiders you can click on any
of these companies and get more detail
on who the owners are that are insiders
who are the institutional investors so
you can just go to the company's page
and play there one of my favorite
features on crown is on the in
Jules page as I say we have detail on
any individual who's ever filed a
securities filing with the securities
and exchange commission so what we've
done here is built a relational map
every name you see here is a director of
a public company and we've linked them
to two we've identified all the
companies they serve on in terms of
boards and we've linked them to other
two other individuals so for example if
you pull down and take a look at
cross-industry directors here you have a
list of every public company director
who served on a board in more than one
industry as defined by the SEC s si si
codes and if you highlight any of these
individuals you can get information on
who they on who they serve for boards on
and and you can actually see the
relationship between each director and
the companies they serve on and you can
see the relationship between the
companies they serve on in other
directors this might be nice for those
of you who do research or who are
thinking about things like board
interlocks or individuals who are
serving on too many boards this is a
really quick and easy way to get data on
that something else is fun if you go
back up and we can go to the main
investors page this this graph gives you
a sense for how the 20 largest investors
buy assets under management the United
States have allocated their
shareholdings across company so we have
here Vanguard Blackrock fidelity etc and
right now what my colleague is showing
you is that um for Vanguard and for many
of the other biggest investors in the
United States the largest holding is of
course Apple but if you scroll down just
a bit you'll see that you there's a lot
of heterogeneity this is X on which is
held across a number of different
investors if you go further down you can
see Microsoft has a different ranking
and what you're getting is that
company's position as among the top 20
'used the top 20 holdings that each
investor has so what you're seeing now
is how much do these different investors
like General Electric Procter & Gamble
Berkshire Hathaway and you can get a
sense for how way did they are in each
particular entity and again our goal
here is not just to provide you with
data those data if you went to look for
them are available but to give you some
information a broad sense of what these
poor
folios do and we can produce this chart
dynamically for any group of investors
you're interested in learning more about
you know I talked a lot about crown and
I the reason we're excited about is
because we want to get a sense for what
users like you think of it and we wanted
to give you an opportunity to to to play
with it and give us feedback and again
anybody here and Friends of the milstein
Center are welcome to become alpha alpha
users of the site but i also thought i'd
share with you a little bit of the power
of this kind of this kind of a technique
because we're excited about statistical
machine learning and the labs work not
just because of the information it gives
all of you and we hope it will be
helpful but also because of the power it
gives us to do interesting research so
just to give you an example if you go
back to the labs page where all of you
will be able to explore today we have a
number of different papers we've
generated that use these techniques to
provide new types of information that
haven't been looked at in the
scholarship before so for example the
the chart on the left talks about a
paper called the 8k trading gap that I
released about a month ago in this paper
what we do is we look at more than a
hundred thousand eight KS that have been
filed for public companies you know when
I was a practicing lawyer a while ago I
noticed this when a company has a
significant material event happened to
it they've got a file in 8k right don't
have to file it right away they've got
four days now what's interesting about
that is what happens in between those
days like short over those interesting
days from a research design point of
view the answer is nobody knows because
in order to know when the event happened
you have to be able to read the text of
the 8k and a hundred thousand 8k is not
even fab has research assistants those
that good I mean that's really a lot of
work so what we did was we took the
technology that reads text in documents
and we applied it to this we found the
date that the event happened and then
the date the 8k was filed we call the
intervening period the 8k trading gap
then we observed insider trading during
that period I don't know about you my
prior would have been there wouldn't be
too much because you're kind of just
asking yeah you're like you're naive
Jackson yeah actually we found thousands
of such traits over a very long period
and what we've done here and in a paper
I released about
ago we show that those trades are
unusually profitable even for insider
trades and when we release the paper in
the Wall Street Journal covered it
carolyn Maloney introduced a bill that's
now on the floor of the house to up to
ask the SEC to address the problem in
the meantime taking up bills challenge
to give you information rather than just
data you have a chart here that shows
you every single trade during the 8k
trading gap when they occurred and how
much profit was made we didn't name
names but if you want to know them you
can click on the links to the filings
and find it out yourself it's a little
afraid of libel okay so that's one
example and we if you go back to the
main data data lab page we've got paper
after paper after paper we produce using
this for example about a year ago we
discovered on that the SEC s on
electronic systems for posting new
filings had a bit of a delay in it took
three or four minutes to post filings to
the Internet we noticed that investors
were figuring this out and trading on it
and we introduced this map that tells
you over time how well the SE sees
website is performing on providing the
data quickly so insiders can't make
these profits the answer is they weren't
so good but then if you look in October
the Wall Street Journal wrote a paper
about the story about our paper and then
the SEC got better fast another thing
you can take a look at is um tools we're
trying to provide for practitioners so
just to give you an example you go back
to the labs page we have on the right
hand side a new tool that we're also
launching today that takes thousands of
merger agreements filed with the
Securities and Exchange Commission uses
text analysis to identify who
represented the acquirer who represented
the target and you can search them and
produce all the information you'd like
to about the law firms that have written
merger agreements when I was a an
associated a law firm I always wanted to
be able to call up my opponent and say
you know your firm did this deal and use
this language and as a result you should
agree to this language that language of
my deal if you want to pull up my old
firm wachtel Lipton you can see a series
of merger agreements that they've
counseled on and you can explore the
kinds of language they agree to in
various representations and warranties
we've used text analysis to break the
agreements down into their constituent
so that's just a taste of what we've
done so far we really encourage you to
go to the back of the room and and use
the software and give us a sense for
what you think of it in my view this is
just the tip of the iceberg we now have
developed this very powerful tool that
can take legal text and turn it into
information and it really is in my view
the first time that folks have applied
advanced computer science to this kind
of this kind of a question none of this
would have been possible it should be
said without the vision and support of
IRA and Bill and of course all of you
thank you so much for the chance to
share this with you and please do let us
know what you think